كيف خسر الجيش الروسي عدد مهما من جنوده
في ثواني معدوده انه السؤال الذي يطرح
نفسه وسط الروس بعد مقتل 89 جنديا في هجوم
اوكرانيه على مدرسه تم تحويلها الى ثقنه
عسكريه في ماكفكا
الضربه العسكريه التي استهدفت الثقل التي
كانت تضم الجنود الروسي اثارت غضب
القوميين الروس ورواد مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي الذين شككوا في الاستراتيجيه
العسكريه المعتمده في اوكرانيا
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اكدت ان السبب
الرئيسي للهجوم هو استخدام القوات الروسيه
للهواتف المحموله على نحو غير مصرح به
هؤلاء الذين يعملون مع الجيش الروسي ويتم
الدفع لهم مقابل ذلك كما انه تم تكوينه في
المدارس العسكريه قد يكونون اغبياء ام
انهم فعلا خونه يعملون مع العدو الحزن
والغضب على عائله الجنود الذين قتلوا فحتى
الان لم يفهموا كيف قتل ابنائهم في
اوكرانيا بينما تؤكد السلطات الروسيه ان
استخدام الجنود لهواتفهم النقاله فيما كفك
هو سبب الرئيس لاستهدافهم بواسطه اربعه
صواريخ اطلقت من قاذفته مارس الامريكيه
الصنعه ليله راس السنه